well I'm a little worried about a ditty
that I call goes like this Bush Clinton
Clinton Bush Bush Clinton Bush Clinton
Clinton Bush bush clinton like that
strikes me as troubling that even if for
example you know one is on the left and
wants a Democrat to win and if Hillary
Clinton is your is your girl I'm a
little worried about any democratic
system where the bench is so shallow
where we have so little sort of capacity
for leadership that all of our most
recent contemporary presidents come from
two families one on the left and one on
the right that strikes me as being a
real problem for the health of democracy
that looks to me like that at its base
democracy is not just about our capacity
to vote for the leaders that are offered
up to us on the menu but the big part of
democracy is being the leader yourself
right I mean it seems silly but at the
center of civic education in elementary
school is that we tell children anybody
can be President or would you like to
grow up and be President or you might be
able to be the president and again it's
silly right but it's also kind of
central to this notion of again that
those people who are smart who are
capable who have good ideas and who have
the capacity for leadership might come
from anywhere and not just from kind of
the set of usual suspects
you